in deutschland ist der verkauf von
feuerwerkskörpern vollkommen verboten an
der deutsch polnischen grenze hingegen
steigen die verkaufszahlen vorsicht
wortwitz explosionsartig in deutschland
dürfen dieses jahr keine
feuerwerkskörper verkauft werden wegen
corona denn die krankenhäuser sollen
entlastet werden
doch in polen gibt es weiterhin raketen
und knaller zu kaufen hier um das
geschäft deutsche büro fans zieht es
jetzt ins ausland über die polnische
grenze weil es in deutschland wohl
nichts geben wird und ich trotzdem ein
bisschen spaß haben möchte batterie
feuerwerksraketen und ein bisschen paar
fontänen für die kinder der hat man in
deutschland vergeblich nach feuerwehr
gesucht sind hier in einigen
supermärkten die regale voll
ich habe jetzt 200 euro knapp ausgegeben
gar nicht so für knaller sondern also
für für leuchtfeuer werk dann er auch
für die kinder und so ich wohl relativ
ländlich dann bei uns immer auf dem feld
oder so da wird es eh keinen stören
noch rollen autos mit deutschen
kennzeichen über die polnische grenze
für den berner verkauf doch ab mittwoch
gibt es stichprobenartige kontrollen
durch polizei und ordnungsämter wer dann
die aus beruflichen gründen in polen war
sondern um shoppen zu gehen muss für
zehn tage in quarantäne
ob sie weste auch das abbrennen des
feuerwerks verboten wird entscheidet in
deutschland die jeweilige kommune selbst
bisher gibt es noch kein generelles
böllerverbot ja bei uns jetzt til
biermann der bild-reporter der an der
deutsch polnischen grenze für uns
unterwegs war willkommen die
feuerwerkskörper die dort verkauft
werden sind das denn meist von legal
oder sind dass diese illegalen polen
bürger die dort am besten gehen also die
die wir jetzt gesehen haben waren
tatsächlich legale das sagt uns auch die
eine verkäuferin auf einem sogenannten
fohlenmarkt diese märkte an der grenze
die für deutsche kunden quasi geschaffen
wurden dass die auch die sogenannte b
eim kennzeichnung haben wir haben dann
ein foto davon auch diesem bundesamt für
materialforschung geschickt und
tatsächlich die sind wirklich geprüft
worden
das problem ist nur dass das halt
feuerwerkskörper der kategorie 2 sind
die sind erlaubt einzuführen aber die
haben auch feuerwerkskörper der
kategorie 3 und die dürfen in
deutschland nur von pyrotechnikern
verwendet werden
jetzt muss man ja so oder so sagen
selbst bei dem legalen feuerwerk es gibt
einen grund warum das dieses jahr in
deutschland verboten ist der verkauf
komplett jetzt fährt man also doch über
die grenzen und sich da so oder so
illegal feuerwerk dann eigentlich zu
besorgen haben die menschen schlechtes
gewissen die dort getroffen hast
nein die die ich getroffen habe nicht
denn es ist ja auch nicht illegal es
gibt kein böllerverbot es ist nur es
gibt nur dieses verkaufsverbot damit
wollte man die fahrer ging das zeigt ja
eigentlich dass man dafür sorgen wir
nehmen's wenig leute am ende wirklich
man wollte de facto das unterbinden da
man die krankenhäuser entlasten möchte
man möchte ich das auch noch jetzt
menschen mit schlimmen verletzungen in
die krankenhäuser kommen und die leute
mit denen ich gesprochen habe hatten
kein wirklich schlechtes gewissen haben
gesagt dass es für die kinder da war
eine frau die sagte ihr sind man seine
romane sie wollte ihm ein schönes
weihnachtsgeschenk machen und ein mann
war da auch der sagte dass es ihm jetzt
auch alles egal er hat sogar ein
so genannten panischer der kategorie 3
hat er sich gekauft wie gefährlich ja
und wenn er dabei erwischt werden würde
würde ich ihm auch ein strafverfahren
wegen verstoß gegen das
sprengstoffgesetz drohen die macht
eigentlich jedes jahr zu silvester die
geschichte wie viel geld haben sie hier
jetzt in baumärkten oder brauchen wir
die normalerweise in deutschland kauft
gelassen wie sieht es da jetzt aus die
leute die extra rüberfahren die müssen
ja wirklich mit leidenschaft dahinter
sein sieht dass mehrere tausend euro
dann tatsächlich ein paar hat unsere 100
euro beträge aber ich war dann noch auf
diesem so genannten polenmarkt und da
waren drei männer junge männer aus
berlin schöneberg da kam dann der
verkäufer aus dem laden mit einem zettel
war das alles aufgezeichnet hatte was
sie gekauft haben und da unterstand 3620
also da kann schöneberg sich dann auf
etwas gefasst machen womöglich mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren